[Musique]
21h38 les bienvenus en direct sur arte
france si vous nous rejoignez le voile
de la discorde la polémique se poursuit
concernant le port du hidjab assure une
affiche électorale par une candidate
l'arrêt mon élection départementale dans
l'hérault le numéro deux du
rassemblement national jordan bardella
allumé la mèche dès lundi en twittant
cette photo que vous ayez s'afficher
cette affiche donc où l'on voit sara et
mahi candidats dessus plairont aux côtés
de trois policiers dans un canton de
montpellier ce espère la lutte contre le
séparatisme demandait alors t-il jordan
bardella à la ministre déléguée à la
citoyenneté marié marlène schiappa
depuis la majorité se divise entre
condamnation par son patron alain
stanislas guérini et soutien de
plusieurs députés
alors question le port du voile est il
incompatible avec les valeurs de la
règle comme l'affirment stanislas
guérini ou l'écart de cette candidate
serait une discrimination comme le
disent plusieurs députés de la majorité
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir
prêt pour en débattre nous sommes avec
jean messia président du cercle de
réflexion institut apollon bonsoir jean
messia merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés gamme alabina cofondateur du
mouvement des droits civiques bonsoir
yamana bina merci également à vous
d'être là jordan bardella avec son tweet
qui a finalement jeté un pavé dans la
marre c'est cela la lutte contre le
séparatisme
est-ce qu'ils avaient raison
d'interpeller l'arrêt mais son affiche
électorale il a touché là où ça fait mal
jean médias je pense que c'est la
réaction de la reine qui fait quitte un
peu qui doit être soulignée en
l'occurrence parce que en d'autres temps
la république en marche n'aurait pas
réagi de façon aussi véhémente mais là
la république en marche en tout cas ses
représentants et stanislas guérini ne
sont pas sans ignorer que la france est
depuis maintenant des mois en proie à
une violence islamique sans précédent
qu'elle ce que celle ci s'exprime par le
terrorisme ou par le harcèlement de nos
forces de l'ordre ou par là l'explosion
de la délinquance et de la criminalité
qui a une composante identitaire assez
forte
c'est finalement la réaction de la
république en marche qui est en
l'occurrence à saluer ou en tout cas qui
est étonnante parce que le le
rassemblement national et toutes les
forces patriotiques et nationales
françaises disent la même chose depuis
des années donc en fait la réaction de
jordan brown avait pas tellement
nouvelle et elle ne surprend personne
d'une certaine façon par contre qui est
surprenant c'est la façon dont la
majorité s'est emparée de cette affaire
sur un simple tweet et a commencé à
réagir alors évidemment la république en
mars je les ai traversé est très embêté
par cette histoire parce que d'un côté
le haut du pavé si je puis dire c'est le
gouvernement les ministres ne sont pas
sans ignorer l'ampleur de la violence
islamiste qui avant pays mais de l'autre
côté vous avez aussi au sein de la
république en marche et bien des
personnalités de gauche recyclés par le
mouvement en marche des socialistes qui
comme chacun sait sont des
immigrationniste et des islamophiles à
l'image de coralie dubost la campagne de
d'olivier ferrand qui s'est fendu d'un
tweet de soutien
à 7 contre à cette candidate voilée sur
la fiche donc en fait le cette candidate
voilée sur une affiche
elle pose beaucoup plus de problèmes à
la république en marche en réalité qu
elle dans pause ou camp national aux
grandes marques français et
singulièrement au rassemblement national
voilà une lecture effectivement
politique gamal à bina en tout cas sur
les conséquences politiques aussi sur la
république en marge de la binah vous
avez cette lecture aussi où la raim qui
se prend évidemment les pieds dans le
tapis du voile c'est j'ose dire ça dit
autre chose cette affaire on touche à un
débat plus profond certainement le
problème c'est que d'abord il ya deux
choses qui doivent être soulevées
monsieur bestial fait référence à soi
disant des des courants de gauche dans
les républiques aux marches qui serait
immigrationniste qui serait pro
musulmans islamophile bref toutes ces
caricatures mais il ne fait pas
référence à la loi la loi le dit quoi à
la loi du 23 décembre 2010 dit que
n'importe quel candidat qui se présente
à une élection n'est pas obligé de
cacher son sentiment religieux
il n'est pas obligé de comme vous
l'aviez dire bonjour à l'habitat ils le
disent rien la table a dit c'est juste
que pour eux en tout cas pour la
gouvernance n'est pas compatible avec
les valeurs de la reine est bien le
problème c'est que les valeurs de la ram
c'est la république a répliqué la loi et
la loire on la respecte donc quand on ne
respecte pas la loi et quand on a un
courant droitisant extrême droite disant
pratiquement qui commence à se
manifester de façon très marquée parce
que les élections qui se rapproche de
plus en plus on se pose la question de
savoir pourquoi est ce que la loi n'est
pas respectée quand la loi a dit une
chose tout le monde l'appliquent il n'y
a pas de partie au dessus des lois
ça c'est un point des shows deuxième
chose je trouve très inquiétant que
monsieur bardella plus de quelque chose
et que immédiatement dans l'amateurisme
généralisée de ce gouvernement ont
retweeté après quelqu'un qui je rappelle
quand même des d'extrême droite je veux
bien qu'on ait droitiser les esprits
mais de là à 28 euros tweet est ce que
le front national car j'étais un front
très militarisée dans l'esprit je parle
pas d'amour est faite de parties a
changé de nom oui j'ai fait ça oui mais
il serait commencer le front et sa durée
pendant 50 ans donc je l'appelle le trou
parce que t'es trop de partis c'est un
peu comme d'ailleurs la réplique en
marche est un front aussi que vous
vouliez ou non
donc quand il sera remis aux appartenait
ça vous dérange pas j'appartiens front
islamique
et où vous appartenez qui offrons des
coptes font arrêter de présenter s'il
vous plaît sérieusement c'est très
tendancieux et insultant vous êtes en
train de dire qu al arab est forcément
un islamiste je suis à monsieur ne vous
en déplaise à mon prénom dit que je suis
plutôt favorable au panarabisme qu'il
était plutôt dimension laïque
donc ça c'est raté pour l'islamisme mais
par contre je vous dis les choses les
choses ont changé monsieur non les
choses on a changé que je connais ne pas
transformer et là on attaque personnelle
ou mesquin et les bacs sur le sens de
l'analyse qui est faite là elle est
erronée d'une manière d'une manière
assez simple c'est que en france il n'ya
pas d'extrême droite la seule extrême
droite qui lie à en france
effectivement la montée en puissance du
totalitarisme islamiste ihh menace nos
libertés qui égorgent qui tue qui
provoque la terreur dans notre pays
voilà les hommes droite alors je veux
bien que vous inventez une extrême
droite fontas magot rich qui rappelle
effectivement nazisme fantasmatique en
l'occurrence à une chose ça aux aveugles
et alors volontairement ou
involontairement ça vous de nous le dire
sur le seul et unique la seule et unique
radicalité qui gangrène et défigurent
notre pays qui est la radicalité
islamique que vous le vouliez ou non et
donc les rivaux je vais répondre à cela
le voile est un est un sentiment
religieux que des femmes françaises
musulmanes ont décidé de porter elles
n'ont pas décidé de porter la
kalachnikov
elles ne sont pas responsables des
cinglés qui tuent des gens et ceux là
sont condamnables on ne discute même pas
là dessus
elles ne sont pas responsables des
actions politiques internationales que
la france mêle au mali au moyen-orient
en libye par exemple ils ont rasé un
pays je vous rappelle juste pour
information officiellement islamistes
que j'étais plutôt favorable à la libye
de kadhafi ont déjà c'est raté ensuite
pour être très clair mots parlent de
droit vous ne parlez pas de quoi vous me
parlez de quoi vous me parlez de et vous
mélangez tout l'islam les voilées et
donc la mise et vous avez osé
c'est là où je suis très impressionné
par votre méconnaissance du parti que
vous aviez à l'époque dans lequel vous
êtes rentré que vous connaissez pas bien
manifestement je vous rappelle que front
national c'est un front qui a été fait
avec plusieurs courants politiques dont
le poujadisme dont des anciens de
l'algérie française dont bref on pourra
pas en dire ce que le détail de la gd910
ils font des provisions là on est en
train de s'égarer
mais c'est un autre débat on va rester
son show débâcle de ses gammes
bruno retailleau si j'arrive à remplacer
une le président du groupe l air au
sénat mon côté ce qu'il a dit il y à
toute l'ambiguïté de la république en
marche dans cette affiche on lutte
contre le séparatisme dans les mots et
dans les faits on l'encouragent
alors ça j'en mets ça vous y faisait
référence c'est vrai qu'il ya une forme
d'ambiguïté en tout cas dans la
république en marche qui font une grande
laïcité c'est votre avis en tout cas on
donnera la parole à à gamal à bina sur
ce plan aussi après mais ce que je
compte c'est que ce que je critique chez
monsieur habib n'a alors moi je veux
bien que vous soyez si vous voulez un un
panarabisme et votre prénom gamin le
fait référence à kavala c'est la
possible et vous êtes vous aimez vous
justement que vous n'êtes pas sans
ignorer que gamal abdel nasser
c'est foutu de la gueule des islamistes
de son époque et du voile islamique en
particulier donc voilà aujourd'hui enfin
la france si vous voulez le problème du
voile islamique
c'est que c'est un étendard de l'islamo
fascisme et la france a raison de mettre
hors d'eau sanitaire
effectivement à la propagation de cette
idée de cette idéologie que vous le que
vous le vouliez ou non d'autant plus que
la personne incriminée dans ceux où en
tout cas photographié sur cette affiche
est la présidente d'un d'une association
qui l'association tabac sem qui est
régulièrement invité tariq ramadan et
hani ramadan qui ne sont pas
effectivement connu pour avoir une
lecture on va dire moderne ou laïques de
l'islam donc ça aussi il faut il faut le
noter
aujourd'hui il faut effectivement c'est
là où vous confond vous méconnaissez
l'identité française c'est qu'une
identité nationale quelques pas du tout
s'il est vrai que cette dame
bod we allez-y faites à donner votre lit
dans l'identité d'un pays ne se limite
pas à des lois ou à des règlements
l'identité nationale française comme
toute identité nationale c'est aussi un
art de vivre auquel le foulard islamique
n'appartient pas c'est aussi simple que
ça totalement faux
quand les quand la france est colonisé
l'algérie bizarrement on faisait de la
publicité pour la gagne c'est bizarre on
les voit dans les gants dans des cartes
postales envoyées dans l'état on parle
bien de la france qui a commise et 132
en algérie avec un rapport cm3 c'est ça
le met bien sûr on était des sous
citoyens et ce qui est amusant
aujourd'hui on se rend compte c'est
l'histoire que vous connaissez pas vous
vous êtes si vous étiez en anglais ne
confondez pas l'angleterre et la france
alors maintenant moi j'arrête choses
vous êtes en avertir vous fûtes de
colonisé par les anglais monsieur vous
êtes né en égypte égyptienne naissance
- ah oui mais dans le foot on sait
aujourd'hui mais là c'est important
c'est votre identité
maintenant on va rester sur tous les
fronts c'est monsieur pardonnez-moi mais
non j'en ai déjà parlé des mois vous
êtes une blague identité je peux finir
s'il vous plaît je vous laisse parler
celle ci si vous parlez du débat de fond
parce que je reviens ce débat oui je la
caution cela que je dis sur l'identité
française qu'il voit mythifié la
problématique elle se pose en termes de
caisse ko française s'identifie
française et ne pas tenir compte du
passé colonial était effectivement
l'identité française c'est simplement
les gaulois mais c'est très réducteur
par les alsaciens ils ont une identité
allemande et française maintenant ce qui
concerne moi ce qui m'intéresse vraiment
se joue sur le débat de fond ce qui
m'intéresse réellement vous avez c'est
quoi je me pose la question comment
peut-on faire une tempête dans un verre
d'eau sert qu'on est dans une campagne
sérieuse et on nous parle d'une femme
qui sur une affiche entre à wallon le
même pas sûr qu'ils vont gagner
d'ailleurs alors qu'aujourd'hui je
rappelle des réalités économiques c'est
que y aller il ya 12 millions de
personnes qui sont sur le point noté il
ya du pour sa population qui est sous le
seuil de pauvreté
il ya une dette publique qui a dépassé
120 de ponsan 2700 milliards
personne dans la classe politique
aujourd'hui ça me choque ne parle de ça
on compare d'un chiffon sur une tête et
je dis bien chiffon à pitre intentionnel
je respecte le jugement
merci c'est important de le rappeler
c'est qu'aujourd'hui vous fait débat sur
un truc est marginal qui n'intéresse
personne
ensuite j'y oppose icloud écoutez moi
bien je pose une question très précise
parce que moi je comprends pas cette
hystérie généralisée soit c'est du
racisme pur là il faut dire dégageons
les arts de france soit on va sur le
débat de fond qu'est-ce que ça peut bien
faire que toutes les filles de banlieue
jeu dans la caricature portent le voile
à la réplique française qu'est ce que ça
fera comme à l'est ce que ça vous
dérange et on vivre est-ce que vous irez
moi bien et ce qui aura des problèmes de
société et ce qui aura des problèmes en
terme de nuisances sonores je sais il
n'y a aucun problème tout le monde a
fait voter tranchant je vais vous
répondre mais sans manquer parce que là
effectivement une touche certainement
une au fond l'une où démarre peut-être
le faux le fond du débat il est très
simple je vous retourne la question
qu'est ce que ça peut faire un pays
comme le maroc ou à la tunisie que tous
les gens qui sont ces pays là deviennent
des chrétiens et se baladent avec des
croix dans la rue ben vous serez le
courrier le premier on l'achète il est
logique de 10 millions capitaux frais en
disant ces pays sont en train de perdre
leur identité
il ya quelque chose en france qui
s'appelle l'identité nationale française
à laquelle ni l'islam ni le voile
n'appartiennent en tant que tel c'est
aussi simple que ça donc vous marrez
cité les problèmes économiques je suis
parfaitement d'accord et vous
effectivement il y a des problèmes
économiques majeurs et loin de moi
l'idée de les nier
mais les problèmes économiques
concernent la voir or le propre les
problèmes d'identité concerne l'être
à quoi bon avoir des frigos remplis un
chômage réduit à sa portion congrue cl
demain la france n'est plus la france
or la france n'est pas n'a jamais été et
ne sera jamais un pays musulman et le
voile très bien là jamais je ne fais pas
partie et ne fera jamais partie de l'est
des antilles françaises que monsieur
mahina ou non chez que vous répondrez
vous avez un problème sauf erreur de ma
part le temps de paroles assez équitable
je me répondra d'abord ça n'a aucune
incidence sur la vie des gens le 7
quelle femme porte le voile on s'en
fiche
moi la seule chose que je vais pas dans
la simple incident ça vous va vous
empêcher d'aller manger chez moi le vrai
moi unités
c'est une affiche évidemment de
politique ça veut dire que le fait
religieux est mis tout de même en avant
peut-être dans le programme en cours et
qu'on sait c'est en tout cas c'est ce
que certains le pensent
en voyant peut-être cette affiche est
donc contraire peut-être à une forme de
laïcité c'est ce sont les critiques qui
sont revenus c'est que ces dernières
heures
oui j'entends bien mais le point de
laïcité c'est que comme le dit son nom
et comme le dit le texte à l'origine
c'est faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas
de tensions inter-religieuses d'ailleurs
n'existait pas à l'époque on désigne
dans deux en 1905 mais la laïcité ça
fait plaisir car chez vous et moi estime
monsieur messier messier messier a prôné
la discipline s'il vous plaît si vous
êtes français vous savez que démocratie
ça s'applique à tous
donc quand je vous ai laissé par les
jeux jusqu'au bout laissez moi jusqu'au
bout donc un laïcité c'est quoi céder
garantir la paix civile s'est pas de
mettre le feu une affiche dont une des
femmes qui est d'origine maghrébine
monte racing extérieur d'islamité
puisque c'est de ça dont des questions
c'est pas une question de rigueur
religieuse
la crise n'a pas de conséquence sur le
programme moi ce qui me pose problème
c'est que les gens il affiche elle dit
quoi elle dit nous sommes tous égaux en
gros ça peut ça peut y en a été le
colobe bai des tonnes mais le problème
c'est qu'il ya des réactions excessives
et délirante alors que j'ai on se cache
derrière un problème quitte à vos
problèmes et les vrais problèmes
actuellement le suicide des jeunes par
exemple tout le monde s'en fout je
comprends pas qu'on parle d'une femme
sur une affiche alors on parle pas de la
situation
aussi nous parliez d'une identité
nationale a bien fois qu'un pays en
europe à surfer sur les côtes et les
sols est sapé le nazisme et ils ont fait
le panier en sourdine on a les morts il
est blond du chrétien et ça c'est des
réalités aussi le caractère explique
tôlerie qu'il fallait crise il est soit
disant c'est l'habitat vous pouvez
transmettre à ses tubes dance autre
signe en outre le départ vous jouez
déroulée à monaco comme ça n'allait pas
je sais qu'elle s'est tournée 2 3 vous
êtes vous êtes bien la naissance un
poids de l'identité nationale
les l'identité nationale c'est quelque
chose qui est très commun l'identité par
exemple de l'algérie qui est cultivé
l'identité marocaine l'identité
tunisienne a on peut pas on peut pas
faire griller les poivrons de vouloir
défendre sur l'identité nationale
réduire la question de l'identité
nationale a du nazisme c'est la
clownerie
excusez-moi salem al hicha du national à
la fin du
l'eba voilà qui est un petit peu mais
c'est parce que l'on finit plus
justement le démocrate fait seul en mer
allait jamais s'arrêter
incroyable à l'égal maladie n'a jamais
facile vous plaît pas du tout
c'est très court sinon on sait jamais si
à part dont pardonnez moi mais ça allait
ah oui si l'identité nationale est
réductrice et réductrice à l'idée de la
chrétienté ou d'oubli des gauloises à ce
moment là vous êtes exclusif à aller
jusqu'au bout des démarches dit aux
arabes de dégager de francs soit là
parce que le problème s'est excusé mais
l'identité nationale française s'il doit
rester sérieux ils peuvent vivre notre
leadership
il faut qu'on puisse effectivement et
bien ensuite compris vos deux messages
assez clairement merci jean messia merci
gamal à mina pour cette passion tous les
deux merci à vous et d'avoir été en
direct sur arte france